yeah  and well two super teens and look at  that uh tweet  i love it  not saying david howell is superman but  um we've never seen the two of them  together and i think as i can give it  how a  costume or something like that in that  picture very cool tweet from ryan it's  like looking in a mirror  how cool and look at that we do have the  first result in the ftx crypto cup a  draw in game one between anish giri and  magnus crawls and everyone will start  their games to on top of the hour in  23 minutes that is so quite a long break  now for a niche and magnus before magnus  has the white pieces in their game two  leaving the arena together the two pla